une classe de 4e au collège de terville
c'est le premier cours de la matinée les
élèves ont remplacé le professeur au
tableau plus qu'un exposé classique il
s'agit ici d'une tâche complexe avec un
support visuel et des mots clés sur la
première partie du programme
après avoir tiré au sort un sujet il y a
quelques semaines
réalisé en classe un travail de
recherche avec l'appui de l'enseignant
il s'agit donc de restituer pour ce
groupe
le fruit d'un travail collectif sur une
habitation sucreries autres thèmes
exposés le statut des esclaves dont la
société coloniale
il y est question du code noir
l'enseignante intervient pour que les
lois soient respectées et que les
maîtres ne n'est plus de méchanceté
envers
jusque là pour que les esclaves ils
savent ce qui les attend peut-être
intéressant dans ce que vous avez dit
mais que je vais nuancer cette pratique
pédagogique
j'expérimente depuis quelques années me
semble pertinente pas la seule mais elle
est pertinente pour pouvoir permettre
aux élèves de se saisir d'une question
des thématiques de la questionner
justement de la contextualiser de
l'interroger le programme de 4e porte
sur la traite des noirs sur l' esclavage
la colonisation et les abolitions un
programme similaire est enseignée
essentiellement en première ligne est
question entre autres de l' empire
colonial français
la départementalisation la
décolonisation sont abordés en classe de
terminale
nous nous sommes rendus au lycée de
bellevue ce tournage se déroule avant la
nouvelle mesure lié aux qu'ovide ce
jour-là amphithéâtre réunit trois
classes de terminale le grand écran
remplace le tableau académique le cours
de l'après midi est une projection d'un
documentaire sur la décolonisation dans
le cadre du festival les révoltés du
monde
l'approché ci est subalterne east
historiographique à créer leurs vues à
un mouvement qu'on appelle les super
n'utilise cette école historique à
chercher plutôt à valoriser les sons de
ce qu'on appelle les dominer c'est sûr
c'est tout un travail parce que les
dominés ont quand même les et des
sources
toutes ces luttes ont existé un
pansement c'est l'avenir mais aucune
n'aura autant d'échos plus simple qui
commence en main en 1850
les indiens la célèbre rond comme leur
première guerre d'indépendance
c'est une femme qui va incarner c'est
une formidable
ce documentaire sert donc de ce support
pédagogique
il est aussi et surtout une occasion de
débattre de questions brûlantes
d'actualité
vous avez en martinique sans doute des
militants qui considèrent et à mon avis
à juste titre que les figures
représentatives des figures daf romain
descendants qu'il soit désespère vous
désengager ensuite martiniquais sont
peut-être pas assez mise en valeur sur
votre hymne j'ai trouvé cette
intervention très intéressante elle nous
permet de ne pas se contenter de cet
uniforme isme de la pensée historique
mais de voir les autres façons de penser
les autres les autres relations qui nous
lie à l'histoire
qu'en pensent les autres élèves sur
l'enseignement de l'histoire de
l'exclavage et plus généralement de la
martinique et de ce qu'ils en retiennent
à bellevue c'est plutôt mieux on en
parle assez mr je pense qu'il ya
d'autres établissements on n'en parle
pas du tout et il sera nécessaire d'en
parler on apprend vraiment notre
histoire qu'on tenait au collège et pas
beaucoup quand on est au lycée et c'est
un peu dommage parce que quand on arrive
au lycée on n'a pas beaucoup de base sur
d'où vient ce qui s'est passé dans le
temps il ya beaucoup de choses qui
m'interpellent et surtout le fait qu' on
n'en parle pas assez au lycée ont joué
mais creuser plus dans l'histoire de la
martinique et surtout que vraiment ça
sera au programme
toutes ces questions ont été mises en
lumière depuis la loi taubira 2001
adapté selon les spécificités locales
avec les réformes de 2008 et de 2010
l'académie vient de faire une nouvelle
avancée sur ces questions dont nous
avons reçu la commande
il y a deux semaines maintenant du
ministère de la dgesco en particulier
pour une adaptation des programmes pour
la classe de terminale
c'est une bonne nouvelle alors la classe
de terminale pour l'enseignement de
tronc commun et la spécialité histoire
géographie sciences politiques et
géopolitiques
donc mes professeurs sont en train de
travailler bien sûr son et direction à
des propositions d'adaptation pour la
classe de terminale que nous devons
rendre notre copie pour début décembre
il faut sans doute un petit peu de temps
pour des programmes extrêmement dense
pour se les approprier et voir de quelle
manière on peut les appliquer pour le
lycée les adaptations de programmes sont
parus en juillet 2020 donc si vous avez
interrogé des élèves sur ce qui s'est
fait l'année dernière c'est évident
quand les lycées ne l'ont pas fait le
programme est dense
l'enseignant est aussi responsable de sa
mise en oeuvre les méthodes
d'apprentissage sont nombreuses
certaines accroche secours de 4e par
exemple va se prolonger fin novembre au
musée de la pagerie
[Applaudissements]